we flew him all the way from Nashville  Tennessee he is the number four  lightweight in the world this dude has  more fight options than a YouTuber right  now he has one big old fight coming up  it's Michael Chandler God damn it dude  Michael bro if you can do it you gotta  do it right I'm a professional get your  [ __ ] together it's got to be close down  I know I know the direction of this of  the sound  you don't  the guy we're leaving out and you got  into a verbal altercation of the last  UFC pay-per-view is Dustin Porey who I  also love I love both guys that was  straight up animasi from Dustin it's  like whoa there's no mics there's we  have to sell this thing you're not even  scheduled to fight I mean rankings-wise  that kind of makes sense but also I mean  I'm focused on winning the title does  does fighting Poirier get me toward the  title